I'm giving gifts of course like
different balls for courts I love these
games all sorts but football Santa's
favorites for this Christmas Santa's
deliver rely on our wishlist I gotta
give mr. Pizza catch passes this year
I'm giving all the kicker's new glasses
Bellatrix getting tablets pavani kay I'm
getting lavish Russel Wilson is a
package for decking Crossing didn't
footie pajamas no it's depends on dances
what are you doing being Santa what's
happening back there Oh Cleveland Browns
whole gears in a casket Santa might give
you the number-one draft pick run for
the first never come up short and
football Santa's favorite sport but when
like a missile bro unzila whistle blow
who's that kissing Oh under the
mistletoe
Oh crazy beeps maybe as crazy as a bee
has got crazy cleats season can change
up your weekend campy like screws lost
robobug attack Izzy sailors got run fly
tossed Norman got beeps like the
leaguers got fast like the Packers got
cheese giving gifts Oh crying I like
different balls for 2016 I love these
games all sorts but football Santa's
favorite sport I'm dancing